[Music]
everyone my name is Peter mark bareword
I'm a solution architect for Google
Cloud I focus on migration solutions and
help customers basically discover what
Google Cloud is and how to use it and
how to move to it hi I'm Brandon stark
I'm a product manager at Google cloud
platform I'm responsible for basically
the same topic so the two of us end up
talking to a lot of customers about how
how Google Cloud works for them and how
they can migrate to google cloud and
kind of what are the best practices what
how to do it and what are the
motivations in kind of what are the
consequences of that so what we'd like
to do for the next hour or maybe a
little bit less is talk to you a little
bit about some of the common scenarios
and some of the things that we see in
migrations and what we wear the title
comes from of a single migrated
application is I think a lot of the time
when we go into customers I think there
is a bit of a an uncertainty to the
scope of the problem the size of the
problem and so we thought we'd bring it
down to the scale of a single
application what does it look like to do
the one application because I think
that's much more manageable and
conceptually it's easier to handle so
you've made this big decision yay we're
going to the cloud now what you've got a
data center inside that data center you
got services applications something
somebody wrote about four years ago
nobody knows how it works you've got
databases that are running storage media
that you're running and is that a
solaris box in the background like I
don't even know what's going on I mean
at a certain point you start feeling
overwhelmed with all the stuff that's in
there they do you want to give up I mean
do you want to just say no stop don't
give up as it turns out migrating the
cloud to be a lot of work but it doesn't
have to be overwhelming work we worked
with a lot of customers migrating that
can be a straightforward process
migration is parallel to building a
house it's probably why we use this
analogy so often and you're going to
move into this house but before you can
move into your house you have to put the
things that make the house needs like a
plumbing and a foundation otherwise
you're just dropping your
ature into empty lot and we don't want
to do that so before we move into this
house we need to put in the plumbing
this is what I do refer to as the google
plumbing need to have a Google account
yunji create an organization you need to
set up the billing these are all
basically need to do before single VM
get started and while some of this is
google account related there are also
some things you need to decide of the
policy of course the first thing you do
is create a google cloud account as much
more to be done before you start moving
application let's go into the rest of
this individually the most important
google that have dual forming to set up
as i am i am can be complicated but
basically comes down to what can you do
who can do something in identity what
can they do a policy to what a resource
it's important to decide who will be
able to do what when you start and that
may not be exactly the right kind but
it's better than having no policy and
implementing it later extending our
analogy it's kind of like installing
plumbing after your house has been built
it's possible but it's messy so how do
we set this up this is actually one of
my colleagues Vic very animatedly
talking about the various ways that
customers can actually set up the
various aspects of say the Google
plumbing before they move in and I love
his animation so i shamelessly steal his
his gift so the reality is is actually
known one way of doing this precisely
visit there's no one formula that fits
every single customer but do offer when
we speak to customers who have these
kinds of questions about setting up
before they start migrating so there are
a lot of best practices that we can
recommend so going through a few of
these certainly principle of least
privilege is something that we preach
relatively constantly to everyone the
idea of handing out only what
permissions people need in order to
accomplish the job that they're doing
rather than handing out permissions
indiscriminately you don't want to
necessarily make all your developers
owners of every single project or owners
of the entire organization you want to
kind of restrict that permit permission
say light ownership of a development
project or being able to deploy but not
necessarily determinate all these other
things or for example like filling
ownership and being able to determine
where the bill goes and what
objects are billing these are important
permissions that you want to
appropriately assign as necessary so you
don't want to restrict somebody from
doing their job but you also don't want
to necessarily give them more permission
than they need to be able to send it to
do it secondly using groups actually
makes managing permissions much much
easier than having to manage individual
permissions on their own having to
manage individual identities and send
out individual identities and switching
roles and then switching what they can
do what they can't do it is
operationally more burdensome and it
leads to things falling through the
cracks being able to use groups means
that you can assign permission to groups
in long term these groups are supposed
to be able to do things people come and
go from the group's but their
permissions don't move so for example
let's say you had a network security
group they are responsible for setting
all the firewall rules all the
networking rules when networks are
created and destroyed and so on rather
than assigning that bit of permission
those permission sets to individuals
when they join the network security team
you assign that to the group people come
and go with in that team but the
permissions never have to change it's a
lot less to manage and it's a lot less
error-prone similarly actually
controlling who can set the policy so
the Watchers of the Watchers does it
work is very important being able to
determine what group of people are going
to say yes these are the appropriate
permissions firs this group of people
and that's the appropriate permissions
for that group of people very important
to be able to manage that at a very
granular level you don't want to hand
that kind of permission out to a lot of
different people that should be a
smaller group that has the authority
that has the institutional process and
know-how as to who should be assigned to
what and be able to do what so it's a
very small group of people but you want
to make sure it's fairly restricted and
another way to increase your your
permission set up before you start
moving to Google cloud so make sure to
invest in looking at audit logs this is
a part of sac driver we audit every
single API call that you make look at
these audit logs start using these audit
logs because and be familiar with these
auto log speeds you want to know what
being done at any given point within the
overall Google environment and then this
was a zoning out so I Brian briefly
touched on is setting up your
organization so within Google Cloud you
can use what we call cloud resource
manager to be able to create an
organization that maps to your literal
organization so at the top there's this
concept of an organized organizational
node and billing can flow up and
permission flow down and so being able
to set this up from the start before you
start moving things before you start in
San shading virtual machines databases
what have you is really really important
again it's the kind of thing you could
do later on but it's messy and so there
are a couple of different ways that
people take the organization concepts
and decide how to use the projects
underneath it I'm gonna walk through
three of these really briefly because
the first concept is the easiest one to
understand all right we're going to one
organization one project everyone's
going to swim inside this big pool of
the single project and everything gets
deployed in there and can separately
that's really easy to manage and and
figure out but the downside is actually
quotas and permissions are tied to the
project so if let's say you've got two
teams that want to use databases and
you've allocated quota force a big table
to one team the other team just grabs it
first well within the contract of the
project there's nothing really
preventing them from doing that so you
end up getting a lot of quota contention
if a lot of different teams are sharing
the same project next option is kind of
to divide it up say along divisional
lines or broader groups which is a
little bit easier you get less
contention over resources but it kind of
fairly quickly devolves into what the
first option looks like where it's not
really enough separation to make anyone
happy what we generally recommend and
this is kind of how Google works is
actually projects divided up by kind of
the say the feature or the product level
so a product team or a feature team
would own a particular project for their
own feature in their own project they
get quota based on what they need to do
they're not sharing it with other teams
and that's kind of the level of
ownership that we recommend what is also
helpful at this level is that not only
air our quotas / projects but permission
so permission can filter down from the
top and be able to be separated out at
the project level which is also very
handy for being able to kind of
appropriately divide up different teams
so there you go and finally you know
what considerations are there for
regions if you guys watch this morning
we announced a whole bunch of new
regions we're now up to think 17 is
what's been announced but there you know
there could be regulatory political or
policy reasons why you don't want to
have you data in certain regions you
know some companies want to keep their
data in the US recently a lot more want
to keep it out of the US someone have it
in the you some don't want it to you I
seem to have a policy of where
applications reside you know you want it
to be as close to user base as possible
generally but you know you have to deal
with your policy compliance issues and
you also want to limit the amount of
overhead of your IT team supporting
multiple regions so all of these must be
considered before you're late if you
don't you know kind of do this ahead of
time what's going to happen is your
developers are going to start picking
and then we'll be stuck with region
sprawl over the place all right Brian so
we covered everything now we can talk
about migrating something right we're
building a house yeah put some pipes in
the ground and you're ready to move in
can we not no no we're not ready to move
at this point Peter mark we have to do
the next part which is the foundation
the concrete slab this is what sits on
top of the Google plumbing the decisions
that come from your processes in your
company what kind of network are you
going to use what kind of connectivity
will you have do existing data centers
what your developer workflow will be and
we need to look at like each of these so
what unlike the project structure where
we generally recommend that third option
where each team gets their own project
the network design is actually something
that could be you could credibly say
that we want to use a bunch of these
different options or one of them there
this is not one of those suggestions
where this one is that are in that one
is not these are all kind of valid so
the first one that we're going talk
about is basically network islands and
that each project or each service
whatever it is kind of lives within its
own isolated island and the only
exposure it has to the outside world is
saved by Odin API or some sort of
consumable resource that other projects
other consumers whether their internal
or external can hit and as far as the
rest of the outside world is concerned
it's a black box and so that kind of
connectivity means that it's a very very
high level of isolation it's limiting
the blast radius for any kind of issues
that come up but it also means that it's
you really need to be very good at
knowing what you're outside consumers
whether their colleagues whether there
are people internally who are consuming
these resources or externally you really
need to know what that is next option is
a slight variation on this doing network
peering where you connect different
networks as necessary say over direct
links though so you connect the network
say over a VPN and this is another model
that we see a lot in particular with
companies that are creating networks for
different groups inside the cloud but
also want to connect back to say an
existing data center and be able to
connect back to networks there this kind
of fits in with the mental model of what
they've already done and so we see this
a lot to variation on that is doing a
network hub and spoke where say shared
services reside inside of the single
Network maybe that's where the
connectivity from the office or the
existing data center or whatever the
case may be is going to land in there
you've got shared services like like an
LDAP or an ad or something like that and
then the other the other networks that
are on the clouds kind of just phone in
to that central networking and consume
whatever resources they need but
otherwise sit in their own isolated
network and then something that we
actually just launched publicly today is
X p.m. so that stands for across metric
network and this is kind of a variation
on that's really not a variation on
anything but if you want your all your
resources to reside in the same network
if you want all of your projects if you
want all of your features when all your
services in the same project but what
you want to avoid is teams deciding on
their own what are the network
permissions what are the actions that
you're allowed to do what you are not
allowed to do where the routes going to
go and all those sorts of things what
you can do is create an XP n network
where the ownership of that XP n network
okay for a networking team they are
going to decide all the permissions are
going to decide what the firewalls look
like and so on and then they grant
permission to other projects to say you
are granted permission to instantiate
resources within this EXPN and you're
going to own those resources you're
going to own those virtual machines and
so on but you are not going to own the
network you're just going to sit in the
network and we are going to manage that
network for you and so that lets you
have a shared global network or shared
regional Network depending on what you
want without having to share out
permissions to managing the database or
managing the network so next the this is
very much related to what the network
design is looks like what kind of
connectivity will you have to existing
resources so we're talking about
migration there's an existing resource
somewhere and how do you want to connect
to it and I think I like the network
design there's not a right answer here
they're just different options so I
think one of the first options that most
people think of as creating a VPN tunnel
a encrypted site site and tunnel between
say data center and up to Google Cloud
and I think a lot of projects start that
way the next level is leasing out a
align with a partner so getting a
certain amount of guaranteed capacity
over a private line connecting between
Google and yourself certainly an option
then finally actually what is also a
totally valid options companies I say
you know what we've got this stuff in
our data center and that's staying there
what we're doing is we are redeploying
we are moving applications by not by
actual transferring a bits but actually
these things are just going to be
recreated in the cloud we don't want to
have that connection between our
existing resources in our ongoing
resources so there are different ways to
look at this in different kind of
trade-offs and it kind of depends very
much on kind of what you're looking for
and what you're trying to get out of a
migration also not all of these
connections not all of these decisions
have to be long-term they don't have to
be the last and final decision on this
we also see a lot of customers say well
while we're in our transition phase
we're going to actually lease out a lot
of capacity between our data center and
Google so we can transfer things more
quickly we can have more wider pipe to
into Google Cloud and then after we're
done actually we're just going to turn
it off so you have to 36 months 12
months whatever the case may be
of a lease line and then you turn it off
afterwards and then finally what does
this look like for developers as a user
cloud so if you consider a company when
leadership has made the decision yes
we're moving to Google Cloud we're happy
for it for all these reasons we've made
our decision operations knows about all
this oh okay well data centers are
closing down for whatever reason we're
moving to cloud there's a very good
chance especially as organizations grow
that not every developer is going to
know about this not every developer is
going to be in on every discussion every
decision they're carrying on they're
doing their job they're you know doing
fixing bugs creating features releasing
new products whatever the case may be
they're not part of this process and so
understanding that point of view and
making sure that developers when they
move to the cloud have a particular
workflow that makes sense and then this
really again this is it comes down to
what a company wants to do how do you
want to make that work of workflow for
your developers essentially internal
customers are you going to keep it the
same and try to make all the changes on
your own back-end so that whatever
tooling they use is kind of seems rather
some you know kind of seamless like oh I
used to be deploying to a San Francisco
data center and now I'm 2.2 you a
central otherwise my life is the same or
are you saying you know what we're
taking this chance we're going to change
everything that we did you know we don't
like the old system here's the new
system we're going to do that and these
all come with kind of varying levels of
effort in operational overhead depending
on where you want to go if you want to
do a lot of you know homework for your
operations team to make it easier for
safe future developers you do that or if
you want to say you know what we're all
in the same boat we're making this big
transition feature developer is going to
help out the operations team as well and
you know varying levels of effort in
between there so if you're not already
using some sort of automation pipeline
if you're not using continuous
integration continuous deployment this
is actually a great opportunity to start
using it because it makes migrations
much much much easier if you're already
using it please continue to do so I'm
sure you've already noticed that it
makes your life easier and then finally
with compute what we like to say is when
doing a migraine
and don't try to change everything at
once Oh try to do something like for
like as much as possible so if you're
using if you're running on bare metal if
you're using virtualized machines
continue to do that use virtual machines
and try to compare or find comparable
versions among instance types but I
think when one thing that's important to
look at when you do that is look at the
actual resources you're consuming on
virtual machine rather than ones that
you have so if you've got a 64 core box
that's running whatever application but
you're actually only at like ten percent
cpu usage you may not need a 64 core
machine and then finally if you're using
containers please again continue to do
so we like them a lot they run pretty
well all right Brian that's got to be it
right it's really good we got we got
pipes and a foundation yeah and you want
to move on yeah so you're on the sales
team right yes okay on the engineering
side of the house would like to do a
little bit more no you're not ready to
move yeah so we built the plumbing in
the foundation Peter mark but the first
application needs to be selected you
know what's going to move into that
first you know theory it could be
anything and there's a lot of different
points of view if we're like what the
first thing you should move is I've
talked to some customers that say it's
only exciting when you move the hardest
thing first I don't encourage that a lot
a lot of a lot of people for something
that's a little bit cleaner and it's
going to create less disruption in the
business so i'll talk about commonality
is not like guarantees of what you know
what's kind of a good easy thing to move
first generally you want something that
has few if any dependencies it's not
talking to like you know 35th 30 or 50
different machines within the data
center you want it something that's
running linux or windows and fairly
modern you know if you're running redhat
for or windows 2003 that's probably not
where you want to start in terms of
getting your application over the cloud
and then this is surely recommendation
taken for what it's worth internals can
be better than external most companies
would prefer to aggravate their
employees and the customers so if you
want to move an internal systems it's
cut inward facing and see if that works
tends to be a little bit better place to
start than just you know your web facing
property
all right I I know you're gonna tell me
no but I mean we got to be ready to move
now right i mean what else is there
we're ready oh you made it I like yeah
you've been so here but we found my god
I know I just want to move we got the
house all right so as long as you're
running a supported operating system you
should be fine you know as long as this
is one application it should be
relatively straightforward you know if
you've got the cic d pipeline that Peter
mark talked about that's awesome you can
just redeploy to a new target Google
Cloud we just announced our via
migration service so that's an awesome
way to move virtual machines or physical
machines if you want to go that way and
just copy the machine in the cloud you
know it makes things pretty easy in
terms of migration you know if the
application has a database move that at
the same time you're only doing one move
here so the prudent thing is to pause
the application take a downtime window
and just you know go slow and go gradual
and don't rush it if you guys get a
chance to talk to the wash state I think
they move their entire website in the
course of 22 days I don't encourage that
it's an option but it's leads but long
nights and stress so I'm going to give
you some best practices here the night
names take your order I just can't we
put them down the way we thought to be
best the first stage the migrations you
know trying to schedule it try to have a
defined period you're going to do this
in don't try to rush this out on
artificial deadlines but you take your
time and do it correctly as opposed to
forcing it you know in create clear
goals you're migrating tinea define
success make it very clear what you're
trying to achieve so that when you've
done the migration you can say this is
successful or this was not successful
and then you may wish to offer guidance
from go on you know what kind of
instance types to use what kind of
storage products and databases typically
you're gonna find your team isn't
particularly familiar with cloud so it's
going to be critical you give some
guidance and then as you develop this
expertise make sure the teams are
transferring it from one to the next so
you don't have to reinvent the wheel
every time you try to move a additional
application within your business you
know as Peter Mark mentioned deployment
holdings it's a great idea if you don't
have it get it will make your life a lot
easier on the long term but the
businesses we see moving really fast and
migration have this capability in place
it certainly helps
and then monitoring cooling so just a
kind of a pro tip here if you're going
to monitor something don't host it on
the same service you're monitoring in
case anyone followed last week but
generally if you're going to have
something if monitor it we have
stackdriver it's a great tool there's
lots of them out there but if you're in
the cloud have that set up as part of
them at migration as well and then
finally test a few migrate now make sure
it's all working and that's some
definition of what working means to you
and now let's look at what it means to
move data just some basic rules again
not to take an order like data size it's
kind of obvious but in some ways it
isn't data size dictates difficulty the
bigger it is and the smaller bandwidth
like the more challenge are going to
have moving data you know relational
schema is tend to be easier to things
you out using very often or easy to move
as well it's not dealing with you know
the fast incremental updates large data
sets or quarter planning you know if
you're going to move I think Evernote
mentioned moving 70 petabytes and or 30
petabytes of 70 days that requires a lot
of planning you don't just show up and
do that there's only so much you can
push over the wire there's only so many
trucks you can bring up to your data
center and we like to look at this chart
it's just a way to think about it to
understand the scale of the problems
some basic math here so if you're going
to move 100 megs if you're going to move
100 terabytes you're roughly 25 hard
drives of 100 megabyte wire it's going
to take you a hundred twenty four days
you know if you can use cloud
interconnect and get a 10 gigabyte per
second link that's same time as 30 hours
and just a dramatic difference in terms
of your ability move things this is this
is up on the Google cloud website if you
guys want to look at it and just get a
sense of the scale the problem you
taking on yeah so in case you're curious
about this chart this is available on
there's a solution actually this
relatively recently released maybe a
month ago so it's transferring big data
sets to gcp so that's we literally just
fill it from that page but then there's
a whole lot of detail about how that
works and different strategies and
advice on how to do that
you know it's prob important to evaluate
different storage options within the
cloud it's not if you not use familiar
cloud it can be a little bit daunting at
first what was for me when i joined
cloud and just because you use a certain
data types today doesn't mean you should
use that going forward in the future so
just understand that if an options being
block an object and the others and
understand what it means to you from a
performance perspective and understand
what it means from a cost perspective as
well and then consider the data
structures you're moving to so if you
change your storage system via where the
differences are and how that's going to
impact your application just something
one thing so this is actually a question
that comes up quite a bit when we are
helping customers move is you know this
is what we're using today what does that
translate to we are using my sequel or
using Pro scars for using Cassandra how
does that map to what do I take here
that map's rectly to here and sometimes
there's an easy answer it says you know
well you know if you're using my sequel
you can continue to use my sequel that's
fairly straightforward but sometimes
it's not as an easy answer if you say
you know we have 15 Cassandra clusters
what should I move it to the answer is
probably not any one thing it's not
necessarily going to be say big table
it's not necessarily going to be spanner
whatever the case may be and so finding
out and figuring out where data moves is
actually one of the can be one of the
harder parts of a migration the actual
mechanics of doing it is actually it can
often be not that difficult it's the
decision process much more difficult and
so I think most of Google like they'd
based products in particular if you go
from cloud sequel to datastore big table
spanner and bigquery in certain
circumstances I think they have
well-defined use cases but they also
have crossover use cases where there's a
bit of a gray area in between where you
think well I've got a database that you
know is let's say not i'm not really
relational i think it could probably fit
into data store or a big table which one
should i use and sometimes the answer
was like what you probably could use
both and figuring out which one is
actually the best one comes down to a
few different factors usually comes to
how much are you gonna spend on
where is it most optimized how are you
going to use it for this particular use
case but we often get questions like
what is the direct mapping exactly how
does this map into that what is the one
thing and more often than not there's
not the one thing there's a few things
that could work so it really does take
actual evaluation and testing of the
particular system to find out what works
best I think every now and again you
make great sums I appreciate you
shopping in so that's it right that's
mean there's nothing else right now just
look eager be though what okay fine
maybe I'll talk about other things so we
touched on this a little bit in best
practices in terms of actually finishing
a migration a lot of the customers I
talk to you when we kind of talked
through this particular flow and we do
actually talked about this quite a bit
as I often say like you're not done
migrating until you actually do tests
because you don't really know what
you've done or you've been successful at
what you've done until you test it and
so certainly unit tests if you're not
doing them you should absolutely be
doing them but run those once there the
in there make sure things are working
then functional tests have somebody sit
down say okay well this is how our web
app used to work this is how it works
now great it works you know keep using
it or you know oh no it broke it like
step three what happened we thought we
set it up the same way test it and make
sure that it actually works before you
say yeah I'm done and then I think
something that people often forget is
actually load testing so let's say you
have this web application that's capable
of supporting like 10,000 concurrent
connections in your existing
infrastructure poured it over yes it
passes unit tests yes it has functional
tests work in the same way let it go to
production and then half hour into real
users using it you realize that it only
supports 10 concurrent connections not
10,000 and that's a big difference in
that's a big problem so you don't really
know if it's working until you figure
out what its performance capabilities
are and so like a dramatic change like
that we mean you know we're probably
there's some sort of configuration
problem something like that you want to
figure that out before you say release
it to production say 'yeah this is ready
to go
comfortable with that and then finally a
non I'm sorry monitoring and it's again
Brian touched on this a little bit we
see a lot of companies come in kind of
essentially flying blind and if you're
not monitoring if you're not using some
sort of tool whether it's stacked driver
whether it's your own tool whether it's
a third party tool there's no real way
to kind of figure out how things are
moving and how things have been done so
you really don't know that you're done
you don't know that the application is
working unless you can actually monitor
what it's doing and again so this is
actually critical this is essential to
finishing a migration because you don't
know it otherwise and then finally that
alerting is great but it's not enough
unless you're actually getting the
monitoring is great start enough unless
you're getting alerts based on what
happens so if you're monitoring
everything and you're monitoring the
right things and the monitors go all the
way to one hundred percent because
you're using too much cpu you filled up
your disk whatever it is and nothing
happens because of that that's kind of
only half the work you have to be able
to alert on that you have to be able to
tell people this is becoming bad a
situation is getting worse action needs
to be taken something to take care of
that so alerting and monitoring really
very much go hand in hand and too often
we see kind of only half of that
solution in there so how about now are
we done for now I think we are yeah what
comes next
oh you get the clickers okay how about a
larger migration you ready for the next
one seriously migrations can be
difficult there can be involved
accumulating see but it always be
complicated whether you move you one
application or a thousand the general
path is the same and so this is
something that we've seen oh sorry no no
i mean so just it's a basic process you
pick applications you move applications
you move data rinse and repeat yeah
you'll get through it and so I mean this
is something that we talked about over
and over with it with different
customers and the reason why again this
is why this topic is moving a single
application rather than moving hundreds
of applications because actually the
workflow is the same and this is what we
see so you take whatever snapshot of
what you have to move that makes sense
inside of your head whether it's moving
the whole thing whether it's moving
subsections teams single applications at
a time it actually is pretty much the
same process over and over sorry I
stepped all over you know you know but
at the end you're going on with a
beautiful house um so thank you guys
very much
[Music]
you